prendre l'avion avec toutes les règles
de sécurité qui a maintenant c'est
vraiment un plaisir faut déjà qu'on va
sur le site d'air france
on peut voir la liste des différentes
truc on n'a pas le droit de prendre
l'avion alors bagages en cabine
marchandises interdites les armes
blanches aux armes à feu
les cartouches et munitions pour armes
les cartouches d'imprimantes les
cartouches d'imprimantes
il ya plein de terroristes 1 qui qui
terrorise avec des cartouches
d'imprimantes personne ne bouge
j'ai une cartouche d'imprimante ok les
fêtes qui vous dit
sinon le titre on n'a pas le droit non
plus d'en porter dans notre bagage à
main des bouteilles de plus d'un litre
mais heureusement à l'aéroport pour
l'agent de sécurité te le dis il propose
quand même de choix alors soit vous
l'achetez la poubelle maintenant ou
alors vous la buvée entièrement
maintenant commence à écouter c'est pas
parce que j'ai les lunettes de richard
virenque qu'il faut pas me prendre au
sérieux hockey andré plaisir les mecs
qui vomissent dans l'avion c'est pas
parce qu'ils ont mal de l'air c'est
parce qu'ils sont bourrés ils ont bu
toutes les bouteilles c'est le règlement
dans la famille des règles débile il est
strictement interdite attention
d'écouter un mp3 au décollage en quoi ça
peut faire cracher l'avion ok tour de
contrôle on est prêt dans la cabine
décollage en quelques minutes
[Applaudissements]
attendez quelques annonces et mp3 parce
que là je crois que c'est le dernier de
suite m pokora
on va se crasher dans l'est plus
pourquoi les stewart avant le décollage
sont toujours obligés de nous faire
flipper en nous rappelant qu'il ya
peut-être un risque qu'on meurt pendant
le vol nous vous rappelons qu'il ya
quand même un risque que la cabine se
déprécie or is ok le cas pendant un
instant vous allez être très très mal
vous ne rêverez plus respirer mais
heureusement il y a des masques à gaz
qui vont tomber sur votre visage nous
tenons à vous rappeler qu'il ya une
chance pour que l'avion finissent au
milieu de l'océan nous heureusement il
ya des jeunes et de sauvetage qui
pourront nous aider à flotter au milieu
du pacifique dans une flaque de
carburant inflammables pendant plusieurs
jours nous vous rappelons également que
le court à tout moment tomber ou perdre
une aile à cet instant nous ont tous
partir en couille dans tous les sens
certains vont perdre des membres de leur
famille mais ne paniquez pas et suivez
les petites lumières situerait au sol
dans le couloir franchement ce speech
des stewards
je comprends pas encore et qui continue
à le faire parce que ça saoule tous les
passagers on veut juste un truc décoller
eux mêmes quand il faut on dirait qu'ils
sont saoulés de le répéter tout le temps
sur les côtés devant et derrière la
cabine
en ce qui concerne les gilles et si
jamais l'avion cra fille ce boulot me
fait chier
moi perso pour être en panique totale
dans l'avion j'ai pas besoin qu'il tombe
il suffit juste de cette indication
zone de turbulences la panique intégral
même à 300 km heure au dessus des nuages
il ya encore des mecs qui passent dans
les couloirs pour essayer de te vends
des trucs et la sauvette ça s'appelle le
duty free et où c'est qu'ils arrivent à
te vendre des objets qui n'ont aucun
rapport entre eux est ce que quelqu'un
veut des cigarettes ou du parfum une
boîte de cloud une place de concert un
caleçon monoprix un poireau une bombe
anti moustiques ayant appartenu à elvis
presley
puis un parfum qui vient de l'avion je
sais pas si c'est ce qui est plus classe
tu sens bon tu l'as eu autant parfum
dans l'avion
à moitié prix jean-paul duty free c'est
moins cher ya au moins un truc cool
quand tu prends l'avion s'est tu peux
sortir ça te phrase un peu place où je
suis jet lag et je reviens d'un vol pour
new york je suis jet lag est de 8 heures
la firme a peut-être en train de me
réveiller en plein times square
bon évidemment ça marche pas si tu as
pris un vol pour faire paris la rochelle
voilà je reviens d'un bol j'étais à la
rochelle je devais te lie et de de six
minutes
la prochaine fois que je prendrai
l'avion je prendrai un peu plus long
avec les compartiments et des rails sur
le sol
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]